- There are a couple of mistakes
that I see frequently made
by young graduates entering the workforce.
Doesn't matter if you work
in consulting, in investment banking
or another high profile corporate job,
these common mistakes of young graduates
should just be avoided at all costs.
From my experience as a
former McKinsey project lead
today I'm going to talk
about the three top mistakes
that I have seen young professionals make
when entering the workplace,
when entering consulting.
I'm going to talk about why
they are so frequently done,
why they are so bad and what
you should do to avoid this.
Hi guys, my name is Heinrich,
and welcome to another video
here on my channel, Firm Learning.
It's a bit late right
now, here in Germany,
which is why I'm not
having a coffee break,
but if you want to enjoy
a nice coffee watching
this video, then please do.
As always, if you're taking any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the Like button,
follow the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel
to not miss out on my regular content.
I upload at least one video
every week on every Saturday.
If you want to see even more from me
you can also follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is @FirmLearning.
And I also have a mailing list
where I share even more
regular insights with you guys,
there's a link to that mailing list
below in the video description.
But without further ado
let's directly jump into it
and I will talk about the
three mistakes that I see,
and then for each of these mistakes
I'm going to share one true
story that happened to me
while working at McKinsey
which I already showcase as the mistake
that I'm talking about.
So the first mistake that
I see many people do,
is that young graduates sometimes
are not really understanding their task.
If they get their task
they're not really making sure
that they're a hundred percent aware
of what is expected from them.
And this is of course pretty bad,
because if you do not understand
why you're doing something,
if you do not fully
understand what you're doing,
it is very difficult for you
to really get that job down
in the best way possible.
And this of course sounds obvious,
but still, many people do not do it.
And I believe the main
reason why that's the case
is because these young joiners,
they don't want to seem stupid,
they don't want to be
caught asking something
that they perceive might
be a stupid question.
Which is why they rather not
fully understand the task
than really asking something
two or three times if necessary
to really clarify all the questions
that they have in their head.
But of course this logic is flawed,
because while for sure it is better
if you directly understand everything
that you're asked to do the first time,
it is natural that often you won't
and your project lead or your team lead
for sure will understand.
And it is definitely much worse
having worked for several hours,
maybe several days on a task,
only then to in the end find out
that you completely
misunderstood the whole thing
instead of just asking a couple
of extra questions in the beginning
but then in the end
being able to deliver a great end product.
So let me share one little story
from my time as a
project lead at McKinsey.
I had a young associate on my team
who actually was already
an experienced hire
from another consulting firm,
which is why I kind of expected
that he already kind of knew
what he was doing and had already
some minimal experience going on.
So I gave him some excess spreadsheets
and asked him to do some
very specific analysis
for some specific numbers that we wanted.
And I explained it to
him a couple of times,
and I believed that it was
pretty clear what I wanted,
and he also gave me the impression
that he clearly understood
what he needed to do.
So then he was working
on that during the day
and indeed it was quite a
complex analysis package
and I checked in with
him a couple of times.
And he always gave me the impression
that yes, everything is
going well and he's on track.
And then later that evening,
probably around 7 or 8 p.m. on that day,
I wanted to sit together with him
and really review what he has done so far
just to make sure he
was on the right track,
because I knew that I needed his work
to be sent out later on that day.
So when I really dived into his sheets
and went into the details
of what he was doing,
I realized that he just
didn't understand at all
what he was doing,
and I had the impression
that he also knew himself.
Actually he didn't really understand
what he was supposed to do.
Because while he did something
that clearly was not
answering the questions
that we were asking
ourselves in the beginning,
and this was far away from anything ready
to be sent out to a client,
which is what we wanted
to do that evening,
and he also knew that this
is what we wanted to do.
So this for me was exactly this example
of somebody just too afraid, too shy
to ask a clarifying question,
and rather taking the risk
of doing something wrong
instead of just making sure
that you're really understanding
what you need to do.
And of course this is
bad, not only for you
but also for your team,
because in that specific case both of us,
me and my associate,
then ended up working
really late that evening
to get the time to fix it
and to still be able to send
it out on the same evening.
The second mistake is to
not think for yourself,
and this is something that I see commonly.
Not only for young graduates,
but also for other more
seasoned business professionals
who just do not take
ownership of their work,
who just refuse to think for themselves
when they have a certain
task that they need to solve.
Somehow many people seem to believe
that if they're just exactly
doing what they're told
then they are fine and
then there's no more
that they need to do
and they're already
doing an excellent job.
This is completely wrong.
While of course it helps
and it is often beneficial
to do the things that
you are asked to do well,
very frequently, the main value add
that you can bring to
the table as an employee
is to think critically about these things.
Is to really ask whether the way
you have been asked to do
something is the best way
to get to the result that you know
your team lead, your project
lead, is actually looking for.
And the truth is that your
supervisor, your team lead,
he will often be further
away from what is going on
in the day to day business,
from the nitty gritty details
of the data that you are working on,
from all the interviews,
all the conversations that you are having,
he will be much further away
from that, than yourself.
Of course he will still try to do as best
to give you the best guidance that he can,
at least if he is a good supervisor,
but there is no reason in most cases
to believe that he can
actually better decide
what know the right thing
is in a specific instance
that you have been
working on than yourself.
So whenever you work on a task,
make sure that you fully understood
what it actually is
that you want to achieve
and then if you receive some guidance
reflect on the guidance and ask yourself,
whether from the things that you know,
this really is the best way
to go about certain things.
And there are lots of
examples of this, right?
But just something that happens
pretty much daily in consulting
is creating presentations,
creating slides and
some of you already know
that I also have a full
course on creating slides,
like top management consultants.
If you're interested in that
check out the link in
the video description
to my course on creating
slide presentations.
What frequently happens with presentations
is that the project lead or the partner
will somehow sketch out how he believes
the presentation should look like,
and then he gives this to
an associate or to a team
and asks them to implement
this presentation.
And then what frequently happens,
especially with less
experienced associates,
is that they then just exactly
create the presentation
in the way that they are asked to do,
exactly in the order of the slides,
exactly with all the text
as they're asked to do it.
But in most cases you
realize that actually
it would be better to
arrange it a bit differently,
that actually it would be better
to include the information a
bit differently on the pages.
That maybe showing the things exactly
that you have been asked to show,
it just doesn't make sense.
And, probably, the partner
who asked you to do that
just wasn't aware of that in the moment
because as you can imagine
he has lots of projects
going on in parallel,
and he's just not that much
into the detail than you are.
So then these associates
create, still, the presentation
just the way that they've been asked,
and then they are so surprised
that then when they show and
present this to the partner
that the partner isn't happy.
Because maybe if he see's
then the final product
he realizes himself that
it just doesn't make sense,
and then it's kind of
this weird atmosphere
where the associate says,
well this is what you
asked me to do, right?
And then the partner says,
well yes, but obviously
it just doesn't make sense
and you recognized for yourself
that it doesn't make sense,
or didn't you see that the whole story
fits together the way it should?
So what you should as a good
associate, as a good employee,
you should ask yourself critically
how exactly this should be framed.
And only because you receive something
of the first guidance,
this, in most cases, doesn't mean
that you can't make alterations to that
where you know that it is better
in the way that you are
proposing it right now.
So think critically about
the tasks that you receive
and ask yourself what you can change,
what you can do better
to really get your team
the results that they really need.
And of course, if you're doubting
whether you're idea is better,
then feel free just to ask,
feel free to just
challenge your supervisor
just to have a constructive
conversation with him
and telling him you
know, you sent me this,
actually I think probably this
other option is a bit better,
what do you think?
Do you agree or not?
Then it shouldn't be a
surprise that in most cases
if you're having this conversation
in a constructive way,
the other party will be super
open for your suggestions
and very much appreciate your ownership,
your input and your perspective in it.
Now last but not least, let's
get to the third mistake,
and this is not making
an active effort yourself
to search out opportunities
for your personal development.
Somehow many young
professionals seem to believe
that it is the responsibility of the firm,
the responsibility of the
company you are working for
to develop yourself.
And while of course it's
great if your company
offers these opportunities
where they really put you on
a development training plan
to really get the most of you out there
ready to develop your skills,
this is not what you should expect.
And even in companies like McKinsey
that heavily invest in the
training of their employees,
in the end it is always
the first responsibility
of the employee himself to search out
these development opportunities.
It is up to you to make sure
that you develop yourself,
it's not up to some manager
or some company you currently work for.
And I believe that opportunities
to develop yourself
really are out there for you just to grab
pretty much every single day,
and I just wanna share one
instance when I was an associate.
So when I was a younger consultant,
what I did as a young consultant
to learn about a specific new topic,
about a new skill that I found
was somewhat important and relevant to me.
So I was working on a project
and trying to identify some
cost saving opportunities
in a specific area of the company.
And now we started a new
work stream on the project,
so a new set of tasks that the
client asked us to look into,
and this was all about working capital.
So the company wanted to
improve it's working capital,
and I always thought that this
was a very interesting topic,
I wanted to learn more about.
Because I knew that when
you are in the position
at some point in the future to
lead a company for yourself,
it will be just super important
to understand these
working capital concepts.
So for those of you who have
no idea what I'm talking about,
working capital optimization
pretty much means to
manage your inventory,
your accounts receivables
and your accounts payables,
in an optimized and efficient way.
So from the perspective
of the project lead
who was responsible for this
whole project at the time,
he now needed to ask himself,
okay, to what associate on my team
do I give this new piece of work?
And probably from his perspective,
I wasn't the first person to think about
because there was another
much more senior associate
on the team who also had
additional bandwidth at the time.
So it would have been an easy choice
for him just to ask this more senior guy
to take on this additional
piece of work as well.
But what I did in that instance,
once I heard that this
new thing was out there
to do that now we're having
this additional topic on our project,
I proactively approached my
project lead and I told him,
hey this is really a topic
that would interest me,
and if that's okay for you
I would really love to take that on,
on top of the other things
that I'm already working on.
And of course he appreciated
that and then in the end
I was the one responsible
for this work stream,
and I ended up learning
tons of super relevant
and super interesting things
that I still benefit from now
today working in corporate.
So the lesson learned
is that you need to reach
out to these opportunities.
The truth of it also is that
pursuing these opportunities
have some kind of cost,
either monetary or time.
For me it would have been the easy path
to not ask for getting this
additional piece of work,
I had already plenty of other
stuff to do on the project,
but I wanted to do it so I pursued it.
Ask yourself as well, what are the things,
what are the investments
that I can take now
in this specific instance
to develop myself
personally and professionally
within the opportunities
that you have around you?
So that's it guys, three
common mistakes that I see.
First, make sure that you fully understand
the task that you're asked to do,
second, think for yourself,
think critically about the
things that you're asked to do,
and third, actively
pursue the opportunities
for personal development
that you find opening up around you.
I hope you took some
value out of this video,
if you did then please
hit the Like button,
this really helps me
with my YouTube channel.
And of course please also subscribe
to get updates on my
content every single week.
Again, you can also
follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is @FirmLearning,
and I also have a mailing list
you can find a link to that
below in the video description.
If you have any questions on that
or want to show your own mistakes
that maybe you did as a young graduate,
feel free to leave a comment
and I will do my very best
to answer every single one.
Thank you so much for watching,
this was Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Have a good day, and
see you next week again.